[Music]
what is the
coldest temperature you've ever
experienced
pretty cold pretty cold but i don't know
what it was logged in at
what would you say it is i just feel
like bodily
like cold like i would go out the
windshield stuff that goes through your
jacket that's pretty cold
and as soon as you go out and then your
fingers are like
i cannot move them because it's so cold
that's cool describing my [ __ ]
everyday life
really easy for her how did you survive
in utah
a [ __ ] big-ass code except for i
would if i had one my fingers are frozen
right now
but how did you what frozen
touch my fingers they're cold that was
my hand
it is cold what the [ __ ] i think it also
depends on
how long you're staying out to oh true
when we went did a show in toronto that
one time we saw the niagara falls it was
[ __ ] cold but we're able to go in a
restaurant in a restaurant in a car you
know
uh i see but if you stay like overnight
somewhere
even 30 degrees is [ __ ] cool dude on
one of our
uh so on our recent road rv trip luckily
we didn't so this is the one where we
went to the desert but luckily we hadn't
gone to the desert yet
but we spent a night in just one of the
cities um
and it's snowing in utah um our
rv generator froze because we didn't
know this is the first time we ever took
an rv out into uh snow
and apparently you're supposed to leave
everything [ __ ] running
uh so that it doesn't freeze they didn't
tell us that if it gets too cold then
the battery shuts down
and then you can't start it back up yeah
you're stranded
yeah pretty much um so we had to stay
there
the first night no [ __ ] heater
nothing
luckily we had our sleeping bags it was
cold but we would have [ __ ]
died okay we weren't gonna die but what
was the temperature
20s maybe it was cold enough to where i
had wet
um shorts because i went into the hot
springs and i left it in my trunk
and then when i went to the car the next
morning it was frozen it was solid
it was in the in the car oh [ __ ] yeah we
were planning to go out and just sleep
in the car too
but after i saw that i was like i don't
think i'm ready for it guys
i like how you didn't say no though you
[ __ ] maniac
i didn't have well that's why we got the
sleep because we were gonna do it
without sleeping bags i know
that's why i think you're a [ __ ]
maniac that's why i was like i'm not
ready
and then you when you gave us that i was
like oh well you have an electric
blanket now
and you know darren he actually used it
at night he goes joe i don't think this
is working
i think i have to plug it in yeah you
have to charge it first
is battery powered it's like yeah you
got to charge it and then you can have
like a good
two to four hours out of it or whatever
it's pretty funny yeah i think the
coldest
i have ever experienced that i know for
a fact it was like that temperature was
just recently in colorado when it was 16
degrees i think that was like that's
[ __ ] cold
coldest because not even in iceland it
was that cold like 16 is pretty cool
we were in a [ __ ] blizzard yeah i
don't know
i didn't look at the temperature thing
on like i don't know what the number
was what does a blizzard look like it's
just like a whole bunch of like
like from your perspective it literally
looks like just white yeah you're in
like like
other pieces of white it hurts when it's
hitting your your face
it's like a whole tiny little like hail
device you have like natural blush
oh yeah i totally did it and my whole
nose is like red like it was crazy so
scary i've driven through a blizzard
before
you can only see like [ __ ] that like a
car is directly in front of you and they
have their brake lights on you can't
even see it
so you're like purposely trying to go
like not gas at all and just kind of let
the car drift on like
first gear slowly because then if they
get close enough within a foot of your
car
then you can see the brake light yeah so
you're like driving oh my god one mile
per hour
jeep but it was like you can't see [ __ ]
it's so scary
hiking through a glacier when that [ __ ]
the blizzard show was happening so we
had to hold on to the group like we were
holding on to each other's shoulders
because and then
also we were walking like right by an
edge where it's like
one wrong step like you had to step
where the person in front of you stepped
because then
you could you guys chained together
anything or chained onto something
no they gave us a pickaxe though so in
case we fell or something we could do
yeah
oh [ __ ] a whole just in case there's
some indiana
jones or [ __ ]
i like it now i used to hate it all
right let me let me
let me see if you're going to like this
kind of car all right so
officially recognizing immediately take
it back
not the way you're pitching it sounds
crazy all right so officially recognized
as the coldest
permanently inhabited settlement on
earth inhabited or uninhabited
in siberia it's in siberia it's a small
russian settlement
it's called
oh my god yeah literally russian for oh
my god
or siberia or whatever it was sorry and
they're saying that it's home to the
most resilient kids
in the world all the non-resilient
that stayed there and they recorded it
and i was i went through this whole
rabbit hole of watching people
well how cold does it get it's so cold
that if this is the same city
like their outdoor market is all frozen
products
wow so you go there and you buy like a
frozen fish a frozen thing and then you
go home and thought it was
ice cream it's just ice creams right
there on the sidewalk
it's not even a cow it's a [ __ ] ice
cream coming out of the titties like
frozen yogurt that's cool it has to be
because the temperatures that they
experience
nothing isn't frozen all right so the
idea that i think so the concept of what
these kids
live through is for us we would have
snow oh
maybe some texas i would have snow days
and on snow days you know
if there's like more than three inches
of snow because i'm in texas we don't
really
really know how to drive in the snow it
would be a snow day and we get to stay
home
right three inches it snows in dallas
yeah it can
it can but it's very rare so like any
time we did get a snow day i was like
you know what the temperature would be
uh i mean at least freezing so
because it has to stick right there's a
snow day there like a rain day here
so snow day we don't yeah yeah no yeah i
was like i'm talking to the wrong crowd
bringing up snow days so i get like
double your travel time to get anywhere
when it rains here
but people still go to school still go
to work true here
yeah we never have like school shut down
you've never had a snow day right no
yeah like that's like alien okay so if
that would be alien to these kids too
because for them to not go to school
the degree of weather has to drop below
negative
52 degrees celsius oh
my god what is that like negative 90
negative
negative 60 negative c negative 60. i
mean let me find out negative dry ice or
some [ __ ]
how do they blink uh negative 61
degrees in fahrenheit what oh my god
damn how do you breathe yeah exactly
like i don't know
because do you like spit and it turns
into hail
probably like you cry and immediately
you get icicles on your eyes
your skin must look [ __ ] good don't
break up with me right now we're
outdoors
super tight what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah
so
cold thinking about that true so for
primary
school kids to get a day off school
temperatures need to drop below negative
52 degrees celsius
children older than 11 have to tough it
out even more
and they don't get to get uh get school
off until it's negative 56 degrees
celsius
and then how much is that 56
because 50 is 61 in fahrenheit i wonder
if they
go to the alps for vacation for summer
break
and they're sweating and they're like oh
it's so hot at the alps
probably uh and so then the average
uh daytime temperature uh
all year round is negative 50 degrees
celsius
what to us i'm like it's that's so cool
negative 50 to negative 56 degrees i'm
like
does it even [ __ ] matter right do
they get sun
uh [ __ ] nighttime 24 hours yeah it's
one of those where they get
like a shorter amount of sun sunlight it
sounds like why would you want to live
in mars
yeah exactly can you grow a plant there
like what do they eat like snow cones
what do they eat
you know like that's their like we have
shaved ice and then they just grind ice
and then put like
colors on them the abominable snowman
from monsters inc
that's all they eat snow cones like what
do they get
it's crazy maybe they go ice fishing
yeah
probably they look like the ice fishing
type so i have some photos of them
and um it really doesn't even look like
they're wearing all that much clothing
yeah wow yeah it does not look like a
lot at all
what a beautiful oh they're asian
looking too asian looking yes this is
like in the region where
it's more than yeah we were talking
about this earlier so that's what my
eyes are made for
to keep the snow out blizzard snow
that's funny
so this is the school they go to and
it's just like a cabin i'm like even
inside of this building would look
really cool insulation in that building
what the [ __ ] do they even own
refrigerators
wow their body part probably just
acclimates yeah that looks [ __ ] cool
they're styled
yeah yeah and then i think the
condensation from the breeze from the
mask
they have coveted restrictions too
they're actually wearing masks i don't
know if it survives there
they're wearing that there's a video of
them like going to school from this
through this article and
they're wearing masks and they're taking
checking temperatures too when they get
into school so
they have the same
and yeah this [ __ ] would look like that
because with the condensation same thing
it freezes it was this piece of cloth
over my mouth it was so [ __ ] cold
that i'm like i can't even like i had to
like keep moving my gator and my neck
would be all
cold because it's like all wet it's all
wet because otherwise sometimes it
freezes and you have a solid piece in
front of your mouth yeah it would it
would be like
i actually liked um breathing normally
than having a gator on when i was
snowboarding
because the gator the moisture made it
like uncomfortable i don't know if
you're somebody in like a blizzard
though that [ __ ]
hurts no no not at all not a blizzard
you need protection but
all right like the but if it's like a
nice sunny day your skin it really hurts
and we had to wear goggles too when we
weren't doing that thing your eyelashes
might freeze off
or that the the the the snow that comes
out it just
pierces your like face tell that to wim
hof that fool was [ __ ] walking out
barefoot like
the cold is good in a blizzard yeah you
should see his videos him and his crew
just walk up the mountain in like
negative 20 degree or whatever it's
crazy [ __ ]
shirtless he was he broke a lot of uh um
world records like those guinness world
records about like uh being able to hold
his breath
under ice water uh like swim under like
what do you call it like that those ice
caps or whatever he
like did what's the the himalayans
there's mount everest or something like
that
he did that barefoot or something and
like shorts or something yeah in short
yeah he's the mind over matter guy right
it's probably north face made up it's
like you didn't do that [ __ ]
he broke a lot of world records wow i
can't even be in our pool for a second
hey what like we'll be in our hot tub
we'd like to jump in
that's not worried again i look cold no
but like like it's really
for like real [ __ ] like that we'll be in
our hot tub and we'll dare each other
to jump in because it's like in the
middle of the night yeah and we jump in
the pool and
after like two seconds way faster for
sure
does it feel like a thousand miles
when you do that like from super hot
like jacuzzi to a freezing cold
yeah jump in the water oh my gosh it's
got to be freezing and i look at like 55
degrees
really yeah
dude i can't even do the cold pool at uh
wifa
i couldn't that's what it feels like it
feels like the cool pool at we spa
if you do it long enough though um your
body gets used to it
so like i think my average tolerance
has went a lot higher or dropped or
whatever
so uh what when i used to shiver like a
chihuahua i don't anymore
[Laughter]
yeah why you cho hawa because they do
they don't know for sure but yeah
they're like
they're always like this what the [ __ ]
am i doing
this is the local like temperature uh
the thing like the place where this
stuff they find out how much yeah how
cold it is outside
that's a that's a warm day to them right
that's the average average
this is why i love where we live i love
the cold weather weather like bart but i
like it as an option
i don't want to wake up and have to deal
with like shoveling my driveway or
dealing with all this cold weather [ __ ]
not only that all the salt you know like
all the salt
damages the [ __ ] out of our cars right
yeah destroys cars
i need to watch myself love buying
california cars especially vintage and
classic cars like oh it's from
california like
it's disney it's never had salt on the
[Music]
bottom
[Music]
you